Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app there lived a hobbit. Not a nasty, dirty, wet hole, filled with the ends of worms and an oozy smell, nor yet a dry, bare, sandy hole with nothing in it to sit down
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周独家节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取独家节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，您可以在应用内订阅。从前，住着一个霍比特人。那不是那种又讨厌、又脏、又湿的洞，里面长满了蠕虫的残骸，还散发着泥泞的气味；但也不是那种干燥、光秃秃、沙地般的洞，里面连个坐的
on or to eat. It was a hobbit hole, and that means comfort. This hobbit was a very well-to-do hobbit, and his name was Baggins. The Bagginses had lived in the neighbourhood of the hill for time out of mind, and people considered them very respectable, not only because most of them were rich, but also because they never had any adventures or did anything unexpected. You could tell what a Baggins would say on any question without the bother of asking him. But this is a story of how a Baggins had an adventure and found himself doing and saying things altogether unexpected. He may have lost the neighbour's respect, but he gained, well, you will see whether he gained anything in the end. And Tom Holland, did the Hobbit gain anything in the end?
地方都没有，也没有什么吃的。那是一个霍比特人的洞穴，这就意味着舒适。这个霍比特人是个非常富有的霍比特人，他的名字叫巴金斯。巴金斯家族在山丘附近住了不知多少年，人们认为他们非常体面，不仅因为他们大多很富有，还因为他们从不经历什么冒险，也从不做任何意料之外的事。你甚至不用费劲去问，就能猜到一个巴金斯在任何问题上会说些什么。但这是一个关于巴金斯如何经历冒险，并发现自己做出了完全出乎意料的事情、说出了完全出乎意料的话的故事。他可能失去了邻居们的尊敬，但他收获了——嗯，你最后就会看到他究竟有没有收获。那么汤姆·霍兰德，霍比特人最后有什么收获吗？
He gains a ring. He does indeed. But he also gains, so this is Bilbo Baggins in The Hobbits, published in 1937 by J.R.R. Tolkien. And of course, we did the first episode on Tolkien earlier this week, the time of the Amazon series, and this is the second. But he gains a sense of adventure, a love of the amazon series and this is the second but he gains a sense of adventure a love of the quest um experience of foreign climes and the sort of satisfaction of being
他得到了一枚戒指。确实如此。但他同时也收获了——这是 1937 年由 J.R.R. 托尔金出版的《霍比特人》中的比尔博·巴金斯。当然，我们在本周早些时候、也就是亚马逊剧集播出的时期制作了关于托尔金的第一期节目，这是第二期。但他获得了一种冒险精神，对亚马逊剧集的喜爱——这是第二期——但他获得了一种冒险精神、对探索的喜爱，嗯，对异国风情的体验，以及成为
part of a journey and part of a sense of camaraderie and all those kinds of things and tom we talked in the first episode about uh tolkien's experience of the first world war there's a little element of that in this book don't you think of the journeying far from home with a band of friends when you see that even more in the lord of the rings the sequels yeah but yeah and and then he comes back and he's had experiences that he can't readily explain to people yes and there's always a slight uh feeling that these experiences have marked him so much that he isn't really a Hobbit anymore. That's right. He's changed. And as you say, this will be a much profounder theme in Lord of the Rings, which is the sequel.
一段旅程的一部分、一种同袍情谊以及所有这些体验的满足感。汤姆，我们在第一期节目中谈到了托尔金的一次世界大战经历，这本书里其实也有这方面的影子，你不觉得吗？那种与一群朋友远走他乡去旅行的感觉，你在《指环王》这样的续集中能看到更多，对吧？是的，而且他回来后，有了一些无法轻易向别人解释的经历。是的，人们总是隐隐有一种感觉，这些经历深深地烙印在他身上，以至于他不再真正是一个霍比特人了。没错。他变了。正如你所说，这将在作为续集的《指环王》中成为一个更深远的主题。
But I think, so in the first part, we were talking about how Tolkien is this philologist. He's obsessed by the languages and the literature and the history of the early Middle Ages, of the Northlands. And he writes this kind of English mythology. And it's full of high elves and people called Luthien and all this kind of stuff. And basically, it's everything that people hate and despise about Tolkien who haven't read him. It's seen as being humorless and earnest and elves and dragons and things no one would ever have heard of tolkien had he not most improbably introduced into this world of of high elves and so on basically stanley baldwin kind of that's right i kind of um and i said so stanley baldwin is you know he smokes a pipe he He wears a waistcoat.
但我认为，在第一部分中，我们讨论了托尔金是一位语言学家。他痴迷于早期中世纪、北方大地的语言、文学和历史。他创作了这种类似英国神话的东西。里面充满了高等精灵、一个叫露西安的人以及诸如此类的东西。基本上，这就是那些没读过他书的人所痛恨和鄙视托尔金的所有原因。它被视为既无趣又一本正经，里面有精灵、巨龙和一些原本无人知晓的事物——如果托尔金没有极其不可思议地将它们引入这个高等精灵等等的世界中，基本上就像斯坦利·鲍德温那种感觉。没错，我有点……我刚才说，斯坦利·鲍德温（你知道的）他抽烟斗，他穿着马甲。
So he's the British Prime Minister three times in the interwar period. Yeah, he's a man of the West Midlands. And he, I suppose he becomes a bit notorious for not having rearmed Britain, for not having. That's fake news and very harsh. However, there's an element of truth to it that he speaks for the English who have had enough of war and foreign troubles and don't really want to have anything to do with it, just want to stay in their hobbit holes. But Bilbo then goes off and realizes that the world is quite a dangerous place. And again, this will be a huge theme in Lord of the Rings. Do you think that's fair? I think Bilbo is absolutely a Stanley Baldwin figure. In fact, some of our listeners, some of our club members asked, tongue in cheek,
所以他是两次世界大战期间三任英国首相。是的，他是西米德兰兹郡人。而且他，我想他因没有重新武装英国、没有……而有点声名狼藉。那是假新闻，而且未免太苛刻了。不过其中也有一定道理，他代表了那些已经厌倦了战争和国外麻烦、不愿插手其中只想呆在霍比特洞穴里的英国人。但比尔博随后出发了，并意识到世界原来是个相当危险的地方。同样，这也将成为《指环王》中的一个巨大主题。你觉得这公平吗？我认为比尔博绝对是一个斯坦利·鲍德温式的人物。事实上，我们的一些听众，我们的一些俱乐部成员半开玩笑地问过：
is Bilbo Stanley Baldwin? And I don't think, obviously, Bilbo is not modelled on Stanley Baldwin, but Bilbo comes out of the same world that Stanley Baldwin is the defining politician of. So Baldwin celebrated domesticity, the country, nostalgia, as you say, kind of introversion. And Baldwin sort of sells himself as a great sort of interwar archetype in Britain in the first part of the 20th century called the little man, the ordinariness, respectability, you know, tending your garden, doing DIY, you know.
比尔博是斯坦利·鲍德温吗？我不认为，显而易见，比尔博并不是以斯坦利·鲍德温为原型塑造的，但比尔博确实诞生于那个以斯坦利·鲍德温为标志性政治家的世界中。因此，鲍德温赞美家庭生活、乡村、怀旧，正如你所说，某种内向性。鲍德温把自己塑造成 20 世纪前半叶英国两次世界大战期间的一种伟大原型，被称为“小人物”、平凡、体面，你知道的，打理花园，做 DIY（自己动手），等等。
Grand pencil, T-forks. Absolutely that. Hot butter. garden yeah doing diy you know grandparents on tea forks absolutely that hot bilbo bilbo is is very recognizably i would say a character born of the post-world war one age of the 1920s and 1930s so tolkien creates him and he's a modern figure i mean bilbo has tea bilbo has clocks he's not he smokes a pipe doesn't he smokes a pipe, doesn't he? He smokes a pipe. And he's in the Middle Ages, so he can't call it tobacco. So he has to call it pipe weed.
大铅笔，T 型叉。绝对是这样。热黄油。花园，对，做 DIY，你知道的，祖父母在用 T 型叉。绝对是这样。热比尔博……比尔博非常明显地——我想说——是一个诞生于第一次世界大战后 20 世纪 20 年代和 30 年代时代的文学人物。所以托尔金创造了他，他是一个现代人物。我的意思是，比尔博喝茶，比尔博有钟表，他不是……他抽烟斗，不是吗？他抽烟斗，不是吗？他抽烟斗。而且他身处中世纪，所以他不能管那叫烟草。他只能叫它“烟叶”（pipe weed）。
So we were talking in the first episode about the different linguistic registers that Tolkien uses. And you made what some listeners may have considered a ludicrous comparison with James Joyce. Tolkien does use different registers. He does think very carefully about language. And it seems to me that one of the great beauty, the great charm of The Hobbit, which I think is a perfectly conceived children's book. So the plot is that Bilbo gets chosen by the wizard Gandalf to go on a quest with 12 dwarves. Yeah. It's a story very much aimed at children, isn't it? I mean, there's no... Lord of the Rings, it is not. But I think it's impossible to read The Hobbit when you're a knight and not enjoy it.
所以在第一集里我们谈到了托尔金使用的不同语体。你做出了一个听众可能会觉得极其荒谬的类比，将其与詹姆斯·乔伊斯相提并论。托尔金确实使用了不同的语体。他对语言的思考非常严谨。在我看来，《霍比特人》的一大美妙之处、一大魅力就在于，我认为它是一部构思极其完美的儿童读物。所以剧情是这样的：比尔博被巫师甘道夫选中，去和 12 个矮人一同踏上冒险之旅。是的。这故事显然是针对儿童的，不是吗？我的意思是，这里没有……《指环王》可不是这样的。但我认为，当你长大后读《霍比特人》时，也绝对不可能不喜欢它。
It's perfectly calibrated. So the highlights are they go across misty mountains. Bilbo gets lost. He meets a creature called Gollum who lurks in the depths of the mountains and has a ring that makes you invisible bilbo takes the ring golem is distraught it's the last thing that bilbo hears is golem wailing after the ring uh they go through a deep wood called murkwood they um arrive at the mountain spiders in it giant spiders um they get to a misty mountain where there's a dragon guarding great treasure the dragon gets killed the dwarves take back a great jewel that they've lost and they
它经过了完美的调校。所以其中的高潮是他们穿过了迷雾山脉。比尔博迷路了。他遇到了一种叫咕噜的生物，它潜伏在山脉深处，拥有一枚能让人隐身的戒指。比尔博拿走了戒指，咕噜痛不欲生。比尔博听到的最后一声音就是咕噜为了戒指而发出的哀号。他们穿过了一片叫做幽暗密林的深林，他们来到了那座山，里面有蜘蛛，巨大的蜘蛛。他们到达了一座迷雾山脉，那里有一条巨龙看守着巨大的宝藏。巨龙被杀死了，矮人们夺回了他们失去的巨大宝石，他们
they they this mountain had been their kingdom that the dragon had stolen from them and they get it back and then it goes back home and that's basically basically yeah that's very very simplistic terms that is exactly the plot but the as the charm of it is the collision of the modern and the archaic. So the dwarves, the dragon, the spiders, the mountains, these are all very clearly drawn from the world that Tolkien studied in his day job. From the Norse myths, from the Finnish myths, from Anglo-Saxon poems, the names are taken from old English poems and things. But Bilbo, as we were saying, he's Stanley Baldwin dropped into this world. And that's the fun of it, I think.
他们——这座山曾是他们的王国，巨龙从他们手中偷走了它，而他们把它夺了回来，然后他又回到了家。基本上，基本上，是的。用非常非常简化的说法，这确实就是剧情。但它的魅力在于现代与古代的碰撞。所以矮人们、巨龙、蜘蛛、山脉，这些都非常清晰地取材于托尔金在日常工作中研究的世界。取材于北欧神话、芬兰神话、盎格鲁-撒克逊诗歌，名字则取自古英语诗歌等等。但比尔博，正如我们所说，他是被空投到这个世界里的斯坦利·鲍德温。这就是它的趣味所在，我认为。
That's the charm and the uniqueness that makes it different from the high Victorian fantasy stories that Tolkien would have read as a boy. And there's one other element, actually, I think, which is really interesting. Tolkien didn't just read stories about fairies. He also read the stories of Ryder Haggard, the imperial adventure stories, which are always quests. So King Solomon's Mines or She, which both were written in the 1880s, mid-1880s, about people going to Africa and discovering lost cities and mysterious queens and all this stuff. And there are definite elements of that in The Hobbit, of sort of keys and locking doors and lost maps and all these things. And you can see why. If Tolkien had never written anything but The Hobbit,
这就是它的魅力和独特性所在，它使之不同于托尔金在少年时代读过的高维多利亚式奇幻故事。实际上，我认为还有另一个非常有趣的元素。托尔金读的不仅是关于仙女的故事。他还读过莱德·哈格德的故事，那些帝国冒险故事，它们总是充满着寻宝任务。比如《所罗门王的宝藏》或《她》，这两部作品都是在 1880 年代、1880 年代中期写的，讲述人们去非洲发现失落的城市、神秘的女王以及所有这些东西。《霍比特人》中显然也有这方面的元素，比如钥匙、锁上的门、失落的地图以及所有这些事情。你可以理解为什么：如果托尔金除了《霍比特人》什么都没写过，
I think The Hobbit would still be loved as a great children's story. Yeah. But what obviously transforms his reputation is that at the end of 1937, so the book's just been published. By the end of 1937, the publisher, Stanley Unwin says, how do you fancy, you know, we'd love to do a sequel. And Tolkien says, well, I've had this train set in the attic, which are all these kinds of myths. And he obviously shows this to the publishers and the publishers, the color drains from their faces. And they say, no, no, no. Can you basically do The Hobbit 2? That's what we want. And he starts doing that and it gets completely out of hand.
我认为《霍比特人》依然会作为一部伟大的儿童故事受到人们的喜爱。是的。但显然彻底改变他声誉的是，在 1937 年底，这本书刚刚出版。到 1937 年底，出版商斯坦利·昂温说：“你觉得怎么样？我们很想出一本续集。”托尔金说：“嗯，我阁楼里一直有这样一套‘小火车’，也就是所有这些神话。”他显然把这些展示给了出版商，出版商听完脸色煞白。他们说：“不，不，不。你基本上能写个《霍比特人 2》吗？这才是我们想要的。”于是他开始着手创作，结果却彻底失控了。
So from them commissioning it to publication is, I think, best part of 17 years for The Lord of the Rings to be written. The Lord of the Rings turns into, it's no longer a children's book. I mean, children can read it, but it's clearly not pitched as a children's book. Well, there's a brilliant moment. So Tolkien is writing it, and he's not focusing on Bilbo. But what is it? Bilbo's adopted son?
所以从他们委托创作到最终出版，《指环王》的创作历程大概经历了整整 17 年最艰难的部分。《指环王》演变成了一部不再是儿童读物的作品。我的意思是，儿童当然可以读，但它显然不再被定位为儿童读物。嗯，这里有一个精彩的时刻。托尔金在写作时，并没有把焦点放在比尔博身上。但这是什么？比尔博的养子？
I can't remember what their exact relationship is. Nephew? Yes. Something like that. Bilbo's nephew Frodo, who he's basically adopted. But this is before he becomes Frodo, and he writes this note. Bingo Bolger Baggins. Bad name. Let Bingo equal Frodo and he writes this note bingo bulgar Baggins bad name let bingo equal Frodo I mean you couldn't
我不记得他们确切的关系是什么了。侄子？是的。差不多吧。比尔博的侄子弗罗多，基本上是他收养的。但这是在他成为弗罗多之前，他写下了这样一张便条：宾戈·博尔格·巴金斯。糟糕的名字。让宾戈等于弗罗多。他写下了这样一张便条：宾戈·博尔格·巴金斯，糟糕的名字，让宾戈等于弗罗多。我的意思是，你根本
have had Lord of the Rings if he was called bingo bulgar Baggins Tolkien's initial choices are always bad because we said in the last podcast that the elves were going to be gnomes but also there's a character called Aragorn who you know to not to spoil it for our listeners, but Aragorn is basically King Arthur, isn't he? He's an exiled king who's trying to get – he's got this sword, which is the badge of his kingship. Nick Scalabar, kind of. Wants to reclaim his throne. But he's first introduced to our heroes as a mysterious ranger, a hooded figure, a man of the sort of the hills and stuff called Strider.
不可能让《指环王》的主角叫宾戈·博尔格·巴金斯。托尔金最初的选择总是不太好，正如我们在上一期播客中说的，精灵们本来要叫侏儒，还有一个角色叫阿拉贡（你知道的，为了不给听众剧透），但阿拉贡基本上就是亚瑟王，对吧？他是一个流亡的国王，正试图夺回——他有这把剑，那是他王权的象征。有点像尼克·斯卡拉巴。想要夺回他的王座。但他最初是以一个神秘的游侠、一个戴着风帽的人、一个被称作“神行客”的山林硬汉的形象被介绍给我们这些英雄的。
But Tolkien's initial name for him was Trotter. So if they were called Bingo and Trotter, Bingo and Trotter, it would have been much less successful. Bingo and Trotter meet the gnomes. But also the kind of the great villain who essentially is a kind of Satan figure in Lord of the Rings is Sauron. Son the great sauron the terrible um and this is a figure who has already appeared in in you know tolkien's collection of of myths and legends in which he initially appears as a cat
但托尔金最初为他起的名字是“快步”（Trotter）。所以如果他们叫宾戈和快步，宾戈和快步，那它的成功就会大打折扣了。宾戈和快步遇到了侏儒。但同时，那个在《指环王》中本质上扮演撒旦角色的巨大反派是索伦。伟大的索伦，可怕的索伦，嗯，这是一个已经出现在——你知道的——托尔金的神话传说集中的角色，他在最初登场时其实是一只猫。
do you know i didn't know he appeared so initially the initial name for sauron was tevildo the prince of cats like kind of old possum i mean it's yeah yes so but he got there in the end to be fair because because the names are absolutely fundamental and once you've heard the names you know basically where they're coming from um so yes absolutely so yeah so he he sets off so we should just i suppose very quickly give the plot of lord of the rings shouldn't we i mean it's quite imagine condensing that in a minute so basically the ring that bilbo took off gollum turns out to be a ring that is the key to the the fate of the whole of middle earth so the whole world of mortal men and dwarves and elves and also these these kind of twisted tortured elves who've become orcs who are kind of monsters um and whoever controls the ring basically
你知道吗？我不知道他最初登场时……索伦最初的名字是特维尔多（Tevildo），猫之王子，有点像老波苏姆（Old Possum）那种。我的意思是，对，是的。不过公平地说，他最后还是回到了正轨，因为名字绝对是根本，一旦你听过了这些名字，你基本上就知道它们是从哪里来的了。所以，是的，完全是这样——所以，他出发了。我想我们应该非常快速地讲一下《指环王》的剧情，对吧？我的意思是，试着在一分钟内浓缩这个……基本上，比尔博从咕噜那里拿走的戒指，原来是一把掌握着整个中洲命运的钥匙——也就是整个凡人、矮人和精灵的世界，以及那些变成了兽人（一种怪物）的扭曲受折磨的精灵的世界的命运的钥匙。无论谁控制了戒指，基本上
will have mastery and sauron in in in the distant land of mordor is plotting um a great military conquest of the world but to absolutely secure his victory he needs to get this ring and frodo bilbo's nephew uh gandalf the wizard who had originally sent Bilbo on the quest, Aragorn who you mentioned, various other hobbits, a dwarf, an elf, another man. I mean, it's impossible to describe it without getting the sense of hackles going up from people who hate this kind of stuff but anyway basically they they decide they had they they decide that the only thing that they can do is to destroy the ring which sauron it never crosses sauron's mind that they would want to do that because the ring is the key to great power so the idea that you would want the idea that you would want to get rid of the ring that you would want to essentially to kind of celebrate your weakness is impossible for Sauron to comprehend. And in the end, Frodo, who is, you know, I mean, he's a hobbit, very short, not the kind of person who anyone would think would be a great warrior.
就拥有了统治权。而在远方莫多尔的土地上，索伦正在密谋……对世界进行一场伟大的军事征服。但为了确保胜利，他绝对需要得到这枚戒指。而弗罗多——比尔博的侄子，最初派比尔博去冒险的巫师甘道夫，你提到的阿拉贡，还有其他各种霍比特人、一个矮人、一个精灵、另一个人——我的意思是，如果不让人感到那些讨厌这种东西的人竖起汗毛，是根本无法描述它的。但无论如何，基本上他们决定，他们决定，他们能做的唯一一件事就是毁掉这枚戒指。而索伦从来没有想过他们会想要这么做，因为戒指是获得巨大力量的钥匙。所以，你竟然想要摆脱戒指、想要从本质上庆祝自己的软弱这种想法，是索伦根本无法理解的。最后，弗罗多——你知道的，他是一个霍比特人，个子非常矮，根本不可能是那种会被人认为是大英雄的人。
He ends up doing this great thing. He destroys the ring. Well, or does he? I mean, that's an interesting question itself. So the great criticism of the Lord of the Rings for people who hate it is that it is silly and childish and escapist. And I think we can safely debunk the escapism, Tom, because we talked in the first podcast about the searing impact of World War I.
他最终做成了这件大事。他毁掉了戒指。嗯，真的是这样吗？我的意思是，这本身就是一个有趣的问题。所以，讨厌《指环王》的人对它的最大批评是，它既愚蠢、幼稚又具有逃避现实的倾向。而我认为我们可以放心地揭穿这种“逃避现实”的说法，汤姆，因为我们在第一期播客中谈到了第一次世界大战带来的刻骨铭心的影响。
Tolkien starts writing The Lord of the Rings just before the outbreak of the Second World War. So we're talking late 1937, 38, 39. So the Stormclouds are very much, I mean, to use my favourite cliche, the Stormclouds are very much gathering. In the first part, I talked about this chapter, the Council of Elrond, which is held at a place called Rivendell, where the Fellowship of the Ring, the group of people who had come together to go on this mission, so Gandalf and frodo and the hobbits and the elf and the dwarf and so on and aragorn they decide that they're going to go and um the only way that they can defeat sauron this kind of great menace that
托尔金开始创作《指环王》正是在第二次世界大战爆发前夕。所以我们说的是 1937 年末、38 年、39 年。所以风暴阴云可以说是——用我最喜欢的老生常谈的话来说——风暴阴云正在密布。在第一部分中，我谈到了这一章，即“埃尔隆德会议”，它在一个叫瑞文戴尔的地方举行。在那里，魔戒远征队——为了执行这个任务而聚在一起的人们，也就是甘道夫、弗罗多、霍比特人、精灵、矮人等等，还有阿拉贡——他们决定去……他们唯一的办法就是击败索伦这个在东方酝酿的巨大威胁
is brewing in the east is um is to is to throw away the ring and to throw it into this volcano and he is writing that chapter in september 1939 so all the various people sitting around saying how are we going to defeat this this terrible evil this terrible evil how are we going to do it it's clearly i mean it it would be incomprehensible if it's not you know the news of the war isn't of course i'm talking the backdrop to that well i was about to say the device of the ring. So magic rings are ten a penny in kind of Norse myths and legends and fairy stories and folk stories.
……就是把戒指扔掉，把它扔进这座火山里。而他在 1939 年 9 月正在写那一章。所以所有这些坐在周围的人都在讨论：我们该如何击败这个可怕的邪恶、这个可怕的邪恶，我们该怎么做？这显然——我的意思是，如果战争的消息不是——当然，我所说的正是这一切的背景。嗯，我正要说戒指这个设定。所以魔法戒指在北欧神话、传说、童话和民间故事里多得不值一提。
But the ring is such a brilliant creation. I mean, even if you despise Tolkien, the ring is a very sophisticated kind of literary device because the ring is not just the key to power. It's not just the ultimate weapon, but it is a symbol of corruption, of technological and sort of intellectual and moral corruption. So the more you use it, the more you become addicted to it.
但戒指却是一个如此精妙的创造。我的意思是，即使你鄙视托尔金，戒指也是一种非常成熟的文学设定，因为戒指不仅是力量的钥匙。它不仅是终极武器，它还是腐化的象征——技术上、理智上以及道德上的腐化。所以你用得越多，你对它就越上瘾。
And over time, you lose your, as it were, your humanity. If you're a hobbit, your hobbitness, the more you are exposed to it. So it's like a combination of, the ring means power, and it kind of means mastery. It means dominion over other people, but also over the natural world. But it also is a kind of symbol of hubris. And it also kind of brings out the evil that is in you. Yeah. And I think, you know, we are talking about the mid-20th century, the age of concentration camps, of totalitarianism, of dictatorship, all these things.
随着时间的推移，你就会失去你的所谓的人性。如果你是个霍比特人，你接触它越多，就会失去越多霍比特人的本性。所以它就像是一种结合体，戒指意味着权力，也意味着掌控。它意味着对他人以及自然世界的统治。但它同时也是一种傲慢的象征，它还会激发你内心的邪恶。是的。而且我认为，我们正在谈论的是 20 世纪中期，一个充满集中营、极权主义、独裁统治等等事物的时代。
The ring is very clearly – the ring would not have been invented by a mid-Victorian writer, maybe even by an Edwardian writer. I think – but it feels to me like – I mean, Tolkien is writing The Lord of the Rings at the same time that people like, let's say, William Golding, he's going to go on and write The Lord of the Flies in the middle of the 1950s. The other people are wrestling with questions about evil and power and thinking, if we bomb the Germans, are we as bad as them? These kinds of issues are absolutely bound up with the device of the ring. Right. So Tolkien writes about this quite a lot to his son,
戒指非常明显地——戒指是不会被一个维多利亚时代中期的作家发明的，甚至可能都不会被一个爱德华时代的作家发明。我认为——但在我看来——我的意思是，托尔金创作《指环王》的同时，诸如威廉·戈尔丁这样的人也正准备在 20 世纪 50 年代中期写出《蝇王》。其他一些人正在与关于邪恶和权力的种种问题进行搏斗，思考着：如果我们轰炸德国人，我们是否和他们一样邪恶？诸如此类的问题，绝对与戒指这个设定紧密相连。没错。所以托尔金在给他的儿子的信中对此写了很多，
Christopher, who was training with the RAF. And this is in the context of the RAF launching bombing campaigns over Germany. And Tolkien is very, very against this, very hostile to this. And he frames it specifically in terms of Lord of the Rings, which he's writing as these bombing campaigns are going on. So he says, you can't fight the enemy with his own ring without turning into an enemy. And he says of the bombing campaigns that it's an ultimately evil job, for we are attempting to conquer Sauron with the ring, and we shall, it seems, succeed. But the penalty is, as you will know, to breed new Saurons. So essentially, the Lord of the Rings is consciously written
他的儿子克里斯托弗当时正在英国皇家空军（RAF）受训。而这正值英国皇家空军对德国发动轰炸战役的背景下。托尔金对此非常非常反对，充满了敌意。他专门用《指环王》的视角来阐述这一点，而这正是他在这些轰炸战役进行时所写的。所以他说，你不能用敌人自己的戒指去打败敌人，否则你也会变成敌人。他谈到轰炸战役时说，这是一项终极邪恶的工作，因为我们正试图用戒指去征服索伦，而且看来我们将会成功。但正如你所知，付出的代价是孕育出新的索伦。所以本质上，人们是有意识地将《指环王》
as a mirror that is being held up to the moral dilemmas that confront the allies in the Second World War. How much evil can you inflict in the name of defeating evil? And at what point does doing that mean that you yourself become evil? And I think that in that sense, and this is what I absolutely didn't see when I read it as a child, but it seems very clear to me. The Lord of the Rings is the great novel on the horrors of the mid-20th century. And it spans all shades and kinds so there's there's orwell is there as well so um there's a very very kind of uh big brother quality to to sauron and his lieutenants the symbol of sauron is a great blinking eye that is surveying everything yeah and will see you no matter where you hide. I mean, again, that's a very Orwellian image, isn't it?
写成了一面镜子，用来映照第二次世界大战中盟军所面临的道德困境。为了打败邪恶，你可以施加多少邪恶？在哪个节点上，这样做意味着你自己也变成了邪恶？我认为从这个意义上讲——这也是我小时候读它时绝对没有看出来的，但在我看来却非常清晰——《指环王》是一部关于20世纪中期恐怖历史的伟大小说。它涵盖了各种阴暗面和种类，奥威尔也在其中。所以，这其中有着非常非常浓厚的“老大哥”特质，对应着索伦和他的副官们。索伦的象征是一只巨大的、眨着眼睛的、监视着一切的眼睛，
And the orcs, they're always kind of telling on each other, you know, I'll give your name and number to the Nazgul, who are the kind of the ringwraiths, the figures of terror who patrol the sky. So it's even, again, just as I'm sure the Ghost of the Red Baron haunts these terrifying so the ring razor nine um kind of cloaked figures whose faces you never see they're just kind of images of the grim reaper i suppose and they ride on um a kind of pterosaurs and tolkien was actually asked are they pterodactyls and he said no but they're pterodactylic which i love very precise but but
无论你躲在哪里，它都能看到你。我的意思是，这又是一个非常奥威尔式的意象，不是吗？还有那些兽人，他们总是互相告密，你知道的：“我要把你的名字和编号交给戒灵。”戒灵就是那些巡视天空的恐怖化身、戒灵。所以，正如我确信红男爵的幽灵萦绕在这些可怕的事物中一样，戒灵有九个……穿着斗篷的身影，你永远看不清他们的面孔，他们大概只是死神的化身。他们骑着一种翼手龙。托尔金实际上被问到过：“它们是翼手龙吗？”他说：“不是，但它们具有翼手龙般的特质。”我太喜欢这个极其精准的回答了。但
so one of the things at the end is that after frodo has has thrown the ring into the uh the where i'm giving all kinds of spoilers away but what the hell people know this that the the quest does to that extent okay okay we won't give away how and why it happens but the ring is destroyed and mad doom erupts and gandalf gets on an eagle and flies across mordor and rescues him and Sam and bring them back. And people say, well, why didn't they just do that in the first place? Well, the answer is very clear. The Nazgul on their pterodactyls are essentially a kind of air defense system.
所以结局中的一幕是，在弗罗多将戒指扔进——呃，我是不是剧透太多了？管他呢，大家都知道这个剧情。既然如此，任务就在某种程度上完成了。好吧，好吧，我们不会剧透它是如何以及为何发生的，但戒指被毁掉了，末日火山爆发了，甘道夫骑着巨鹰飞越莫多尔，救出了他和山姆并把他们带了回来。人们会问：“嗯，他们为什么一开始不这么做呢？”答案非常明确。骑着翼手龙的戒灵本质上是一种防空系统。
You can't penetrate it until they've been destroyed, which they do once the ring gets destroyed. That's a very clear power. Clearly, how you defend territory from aerial intrusion is absolutely a part of it and all the more so because tolkien was an air raid warden oh was he i didn't know that that's a very nice um he was so he was an air raid warden in north oxford and again in um the echoes of the blitz the echo of the aerial war are through Lord of the Rings. So you have, with a piercing cry out of the dim sky fell the winged shadows, the Nazgul stooping to the kill. And this could be the war in heaven, or it could be Stukas. And Tolkien describes people in a besieged city, besieged by the Nazgul.
在你消灭它们之前，你无法突破防线——而一旦戒指被毁，它们自然就被消灭了。这是一种非常明确的力量。显而易见，如何防御领空的入侵绝对是其中的一部分，特别是考虑到托尔金曾是一名空袭监视员。哦，是吗？我不知道这件事。这真是个非常美妙的……他曾是北牛津的一名空袭监视员。同样，在……闪电战的回响、空中战争的回响贯穿了整部《指环王》。所以你会发现：“伴随着昏暗天空中传来的刺耳尖叫，长着翅膀的阴影坠落了，戒灵俯冲下来进行残酷的杀戮。”这可以是对天堂之战的描写，也可以是斯图卡轰炸机。托尔金描绘了被戒灵围困的城市中的人们：
They thought no more of war, but only of hiding and crawling and of death. And that could be about the Germans bombing London, or it could be about the British bombing Hamburg. But Tolkien is also very aware, isn't he? I mean, that thing about the British bombing Hamburg, he's aware in a way that previous writers of this kind of adventure story had not been, I think, of the moral ambiguity of the age. So we talked, when we were talking about The Hobbit,
“他们不再去想战争，而只想躲藏、匍匐和死亡。”这既可以是指德国人轰炸伦敦，也可以是指英国人轰炸汉堡。但托尔金也十分清醒，不是吗？我的意思是，关于英国人轰炸汉堡的那种事，我认为他以一种前几代这类冒险故事的作家所没有的清醒，意识到了那个时代的道德模糊性。所以我们谈过，当我们讨论《霍比特人》时，
you mentioned this character Gollum that Bilbo gets the ring from. So Gollum is this sort of wizened goblin-like creature who it turns out used to be a hobbit who has been corrupted. And were this a Victorian story? So some people have said Gollum is a kind of vision of Grendel from Beowulf, Tolkien's great sort of academic obsession, or he's a vision, he's a version of the character Gagul from Ryder Haggard's book, King Solomon's Minds,
你提到了这个角色——比尔博从他那里得到戒指的咕噜。所以咕噜是一个饱经风霜的、像地精一样的生物，后来发现他曾经是个遭到腐化的霍比特人。如果这是一个维多利亚时代的故事呢？所以有人说咕噜是《贝奥武夫》（托尔金最大的学术痴迷）中格兰戴尔的一种幻象，或者他是莱德·哈格德的书《所罗门王的宝藏》中加古尔（Gagul）这个角色的一个版本，
Tolkien's great favourite when he was a boy. But actually, as The Lord of the Rings goes on, it becomes clear that Gollum and Frodo, there's a real Jekyll and Hyde quality to them, that in some ways they are mirrors to one another. And actually, as the book goes on, Gollum becomes more like Frodo and Frodo becomes more like Gollum. So the classic thing that people say who hate Tolkien and hate The Lord of the Rings is it's very simplistic. It's goodies and baddies, kind of black hats and white hats. And actually, that's not really true at all. The great hero, Frodo, by the end of the book, he's becoming increasingly corrupted. And the lines between good and evil are becoming increasingly blurred. And again,
而《所罗门王的宝藏》是托尔金小时候的最爱。但实际上，随着《指环王》的推进，人们越来越清楚地发现，咕噜和弗罗多之间有着真正的“杰基尔与海德”式的特质，在某种程度上，他们是彼此的镜子。事实上，随着故事的发展，咕噜变得越来越像弗罗多，而弗罗多也变得越来越像咕噜。所以那些痛恨托尔金、痛恨《指环王》的人经常说的一句经典的话是：它非常单一，就是好人和坏人，黑帽和白帽。但实际上，这根本不是真的。伟大的英雄弗罗多，到了书的结尾，他正日渐受到腐蚀，善与恶之间的界限也日渐模糊。同样的，
I think that's something that you write in the 1940s, but you wouldn't have written in the 1840s or the 1890s even. Yes, I think that's true. And I think that there are morally complex figures who are redeemed or who are lost. I think the idea that it's just goodies and baddies, only somebody who hasn't read the book could think that. However, I do think that that criticism is responding to something that I think is precisely what has made Lord of the Rings so successful, which is that it does have a very strong, unrelativistic sense of good and evil. And Tolkien is a Catholic. He believes
我认为这是你在 20 世纪 40 年代才会写出来的东西，但在 1840 年代或甚至是 1890 年代，你是绝对写不出来的。是的，我认为这是真的。而且我认为其中存在着许多道德复杂的角色，他们得到了救赎，或者走向了迷失。我认为那种“里面只有好人和坏人”的想法，只有没读过这本书的人才会这么想。然而，我确实认为这种批评回应了一种恰恰造就了《指环王》巨大成功的特质，那就是它确实拥有非常强烈、非相对主义的善恶观。托尔金是一名天主教徒。他信仰
in good and evil. He believes in God. He believes in hell. And I think a huge part of the reason for the Lord of the Rings success is that it packages for people who may not be Christian, who may find a lot of the institutional baggage of Christianity off-putting, who may find a lot of the theological implications of Christianity unsettling, it packages for them the incredible drama of that Christian story of heaven and hell, of redemption, of their being good, of their being evil, in a way that is clearly incredibly powerful. Well, that's interesting that you say that, Tom, because of course, in some ways, it would appear to be a pagan book, right? It draws inspiration from the Norse myths. The characters don't go to church. There are no churches, it seems. There's no talk of God.
善与恶。他信仰上帝。他信仰地狱。我认为《指环王》之所以如此成功，很大一部分原因在于：它为那些可能并非基督徒、可能会对基督教许多体制包袱感到反感、可能会对基督教许多神学暗示感到不安的人们，打包呈现了基督教关于天堂与地狱、救赎、善与恶的不可思议的宏大戏剧，而这种呈现方式显然具有难以置信的强大力量。嗯，汤姆，你这么说很有意思，因为从某种意义上说，它似乎是一本异教徒的书，对吧？它汲取了北欧神话的灵感。里面的角色不去教堂。似乎没有教堂。没有关于上帝的谈话。
There's obviously no talk of Christ. So tell us about some of the ways that, well, the medieval quality and the, you know, the 1930s, 1940s waistcoat wearing, T-fork wielding quality of middle England. And I think there's a similar tension between the fact that Tolkien is a very, very devout Catholic. I mean, a really devout Catholic, but he's also obsessed by the literature and the spirit of the old North, as he puts it, which is pre-Christian and in which characters live believing that everything is going to be destroyed and that all you can do is show courage in the face of utter destruction. And that is, again, it's an incredibly creative tension, I think, that runs throughout the book. So God is not mentioned in the book. There's nothing that we would recognize as religion in Lord of the Rings. There's no overt reference to anything that's Christian, but
显然也没有关于基督的谈话。那么，请跟我们聊聊其中的一些方式——嗯，那种中世纪的特质，以及中产阶级英国那种 1930 年代、1940 年代穿着马甲、挥舞着 T 型叉的特质。我认为，在托尔金是一个非常非常虔诚的天主教徒这一事实之间，存在着一种类似的张力。我的意思是，他是一个真正虔诚的天主教徒，但他同时也痴迷于他所谓的“北方旧日”的文学与精神——那是前基督教时期的，在那里的角色活着时坚信一切都将毁灭，而你所能做的就是在彻底的毁灭面前展现出勇气。这又是一个贯穿全书的、极其具有创造力的张力，我认为。所以书中没有提到上帝。在《指环王》中没有任何我们能认出的宗教内容。没有任何对基督教事物的公开提及，但是
the Christian elements are clearly very, very present, of which the most obvious is the way in which Frodo and the Fellowship of the Ring generally are committed to the idea that rather than use something that will make you strong, you throw it away. And the echo there of the Christian idea of the crucifixion, that God himself becomes weak and suffers death rather than kind of manifesting himself in glory. Yeah, the emphasis on sacrifice. Yeah. So Christ gives up his divine power to suffer death and thereby to redeem the world. And that is very clearly intended by Tolkien because the date that he gives for the destruction of Sauron, the defeat of Sauron, the destruction of the ring is the same day that in Christian mythology,
基督教的元素显然非常非常明显，其中最明显的就是弗罗多和整个魔戒远征队所信奉的理念：比起使用某种能让你变强的东西，不如把它毁掉。这里呼应了基督教关于十字架受难的理念：上帝为了拯救世界，选择让自己变得软弱并承受死亡，而不是以荣耀的姿态展现自己。是的，强调牺牲。是的。所以基督放弃了他的神圣力量去承受死亡，从而救赎了世界。这显然是托尔金刻意为之的，因为他给出的索伦毁灭、索伦战败、魔戒销毁的日期，与基督教神话中
it's the date of the creation of light. When God says, let there be light, it's the date of the the creation of light you know when god says let there be light it's the it's the date that abraham is supposed to have been told to sacrifice isaac and is prevented from doing it uh it's the date that um christ is conceived in the virgin's womb it's the that he suffers death uh 25th of march that is that is a very clear signal, I think, as to what Tolkien is doing. He's trying to kind of preserve this. I mean, what's odd about Lord of the Rings and what's odd about Tolkien is that in some sense, he clearly believes that the plot of Lord of the Rings really happened. That in some sense, elves and dwarves and everybody did kind of exist. And to that extent, I think he sees it. So Christian writers had this idea that what they called a preparatio evangelium, that pagans were in some sense aware of what was to
创造之光的日期是同一天。当上帝说“要有光”时，那是传说中亚伯拉罕被命令献祭以撒并被阻止的日期，那是基督在童贞女腹中受孕的日期，那是他承受死亡的日期——3月25日。这是一个非常明确的信号，表明托尔金在做什么。他试图在某种程度上保留这一点。我的意思是，《指环王》和托尔金奇怪的地方在于，从某种意义上说，他显然相信《指环王》的剧情真的发生过。在某种程度上，他相信精灵、矮人和所有人确实存在过。正因如此，我认为他将其视作——基督教作家曾有一种被称为“福音预备”（preparatio evangelium）的观念，即异教徒在某种程度上意识到了即将到来的事物、即将到来的基督教故事，并且其中存在着预兆。我认为这就是托尔金在《指环王》中所做的事情。《指环王》在那种方式上发挥了作用。我认为这种力量是对人们为什么会有这种感触的一个强有力的解释。而且可能不只是填补了英国人生活中某种基督教形状的空白，更确切地说，是填补了天主教形状的空白。噢，这可真是一个大胆的论断，汤姆。嗯，所以《指环王》讲的是失去。是的。除了人类、除了《指环王》中的人类之外，每个人到最后都在失去。他们摧毁了索伦，但结果他们自己也被摧毁了。所以精灵、矮人——嗯，矮人们将会
come, the Christian story that was to come, and there are foreshadowings of it. And I think that that is what Tolkien is doing in Lord of the Rings. Lord of the Rings serves in that way. And I think that that kind of power is a really strong explanation for why people feel it. And it may be that it's not just filling a kind of Christianity-shaped hole in English life, but specifically a Catholic-shaped hole. Ooh, that's a big claim, Tom. Well, so Lord of the rings is about loss yeah everybody everybody apart from humans apart from men in lord of the rings ends up losing they destroy sauron but as a result they themselves are destroyed so the elves the dwarves the well the dwarves are going
前往他们的地下巢穴，不是吗？但甚至大概连霍比特人也……他们所有人都会逐渐消逝。因为每个人都说人类的世界是一个新时代。中洲第三纪元的多元文化大熔炉已经注定要灭亡了。而精灵们实际上也永远离开了中洲，不是吗？他们消失进入了相当于天堂的地方，我想。所以那里存在着某种缺失。在某种层面上，这显然反映了托尔金在战争中遭受的失落感、对朋友逝去的悲痛。这反映出他去了塞尔霍尔德（Sarehole），却发现那里已经变成了一个郊区。嗯，马修·莱昂斯
to go off to their to their underground lairs aren't they but even presumably the hobbits they they're all going to fade. Because everybody says the world of men, this is a new age. The great sort of polycultural mix of the third age of Middle Earth is doomed. And the elves actually leave Middle Earth for good, don't they? They disappear off into the equivalent of heaven, I suppose. And so there's a kind of absence there, which clearly for Tolkien on one level is about the sense of loss that he suffered in the war, the loss of his friends. It's about the sense of loss that he goes to Serhol and it's been turned into a suburb. Well, there's a fabulous book by Matthew
写过一本极棒的书——我不知道你有没有读过——叫《去去就回》（There and Back Again），他在书中沿着托尔金的足迹走了一遍。他指出了一件我以前不知道的事：书中曾对夏尔的命运有过这样一种设想：在最初的草稿中，那里建起了一座巨大的巧克力工厂。哦，天哪，伯恩维尔（Bournville）。也就是离塞尔霍尔德不远的地方。所以很显然，这里有一种观念，认为那是失去——森林被毁坏了，然后盖起了巧克力工厂。那是生产吉百利牛奶巧克力的地方。但托尔金以最宏大的视角看待这一切。所以他说：“我是一名基督徒，确切地说是一名罗马天主教徒，因此我不指望历史会是什么别的样子，它只能是一场漫长的失败，尽管它包含着——并且在一则传说中可能会更清晰、更动人地包含着——某些最终胜利的样本或吉光片羽。”
Lyons. I don't know if you've read it there and back again, where he goes around following in the footsteps of Tolkien. And he points out, which I didn't know, that there's this vision of what will happen to the Shire. And in the very first draft, this great chocolate factory gets built. Oh my God, Bourneville. So Bourneville, which is just down the road from Zarehold. So obviously there's this idea that that's loss, that the woods get destroyed and you have chocolate factories built. It's the right way for Cabra's dairy milk. But Tolkien sees this in the broadest sense. So he said, I am a Christian and indeed a Roman Catholic so that I do not expect history to be anything but a long defeat, though it contains, and in a legend may contain more clearly and movingly, some samples or glimpses of final
所以，只有在一个新教国家长大的天主教徒，才能以这种方式来架构基督教的历史。但这呼应了加拉德瑞尔的一句名言。加拉德瑞尔是精灵女王，也是亚马逊剧集中我搜集到的主要角色。她说，她是一位精灵女王，当魔戒被毁时，她所有的力量也将被消灭，但她坚定地认为，摧毁魔戒是取胜的唯一途径。因此，她实质上是允许自己的力量在更伟大的胜利事业中被毁灭。她完美地呼应了托尔金的那些台词。她说：“在世界历经的岁月里，我们并肩作战，经历了一场漫长的失败。”好吧，“漫长的失败”这个概念听起来很像北欧神话里的点子，不是吗？维京人对他们的世界和命运有一种
victory. So only a Catholic growing up in a Protestant country, I think, could frame Christian history perhaps in quite that way. But it echoes a very famous line from Galadriel, who is the queen of the elves, who is the main figure I gather in the Amazon series. And she says, she's an elvish queen who who's whose whole power will be destroyed when the ring is destroyed but who is committed to the idea that that destroying the ring is the only way to win so she is essentially allowing her own power to be destroyed in the cause of a greater victory and she she echoes exactly that those lines of tolkien she says together through the ages of the world we have fought the long defeat well that idea the long defeat is quite a norse myth idea though isn't it they they believe there
可怕的宿命论。绝对是的，但托尔金赋予它的奇妙转变是，把它重新校准为一个天主教的、——一个基督教的故事。并且在终结之日，终局将会胜利，一切都将得到救赎，一切都将恢复原貌，一切都将被赋予新的生命。我的意思是，我认为有趣的是——我同意你的看法，托尔金的天主教信仰对他而言极其重要，并且他显然觉得这种信仰存在于《指环王》的每一页中。但有趣的是，读者往往看不到这一点。而且对于那些缺乏共鸣的读者来说，它绝不像他的朋友 C.S. 儒勒（C.S. Lewis）的《狮子、女巫和魔衣橱》中的基督教色彩那样显眼。我的意思是，人们真的、真的会对其进行强烈的抵触。我的意思是，我喜欢 C.S. 刘易斯的书，但人们对其产生抵触，是因为他们认为那是纯粹的基督教护教论。但没有人真正这样评价《指环王》，对吧？他们不会，因为《指环王》并不是《狮子、女巫和魔衣橱》那种充满寓言色彩的作品。它要奇怪得多。而且我认为托尔金的基督教色彩要奇怪得多，因为它贯穿着一种源于他对北方传说着迷的悲观主义色彩。并且我认为，这也是他将其与当代事件的回响融合在一起的方式。所以我们谈到了艾略特，T.S. 艾略特。
was a terrible fatalism to the sort of the vikings sense of their world and their destiny absolutely but the weird spin that tolkien gives that is to recalibrate it as a catholic yeah as as a christian story and that at the end, the end of days, victory will be won, and everything will be redeemed, and everything will be restored, and everything will be given back to life. I mean, I think the interesting thing about, I agree with you that Tolkien's Catholicism is tremendously important to him, and clearly he felt that it was there on every page of the Lord of the Rings. But it's interesting that the readers don't see that often. And it's certainly not as glaring to unsympathetic readers as, let's say, the Christianity in The Lion, the Witch,
维京人对他们世界和命运的看法中确实有一种可怕的宿命论，但托尔金赋予它的奇妙转变是，作为一个天主教徒——是的，作为一个基督教故事——重新审视它，即在末日时，胜利终将到来，一切都将得到救赎，一切都将被恢复，一切都将重获新生。我的意思是，我认为有趣的是，我同意你的看法，托尔金的天主教信仰对他来说极其重要，而且很显然，他觉得《指环王》的每一页都流露出这种信仰。但有趣的是，读者往往看不出来。对于那些缺乏共鸣的读者来说，它当然不像，比方说，《狮子、女巫……》中的基督教色彩那样显眼，
and the Wardrobe, his friend. I mean, people really, really sort of kick against. I mean, I love C.S. Lewis's books, but people kick against them because they think it's pure Christian apologetics. But nobody really says that about The Lord of the Rings, do they? They don't, because it's not an allegory in the way that The Lion, the Witch and the Wardrobe is. It's much stranger than that. And I think that Tolkien's Christianity is much stranger, because it's shot through with this sense of pessimism that derives from his fascination with the Northern legends. And I think also the way in which he fuses it with echoes of contemporary events. So we talked about Elliot, T.S. Elliot,
以及《魔衣橱》（他朋友的作品）。我的意思是，人们真的非常排斥。我的意思是，我喜欢C·S·刘易斯的书，但人们排斥它们，是因为他们认为那是纯粹的基督教辩护学。但没有人会这样评价《指环王》，对吧？他们不会，因为它不像《狮子、女巫和魔衣橱》那样是一个寓言。它比那要奇特得多。而且我认为托尔金的基督教信仰要奇特得多，因为它渗透着一种悲观主义色彩，这种悲观主义源于他对北方传奇的迷恋。而且我认为，他将这种信仰与当代事件的迴响融合在一起的方式也是如此。所以我们谈到了艾略特，T·S·艾略特，
who was also an air raid warden during the war, as Tolkien was during the Blitz. And in the Four Quartets, so Little Gidding most famously, Elliot is looking back to history to make sense of the horrors of the present, pretty much in the same way that Tolkien is. And in that, he meets with a kind of ghostly figure in the midst of an air raid. And then Eliot writes that in the disfigured street, he left me with a kind of valediction and faded on the blowing of the
他也是战争时期的空袭民防员，就像托尔金在伦敦大轰炸期间一样。而在《四首四重奏》中，最著名的是《小吉丁》，艾略特在回顾历史，以理解当下的恐怖，这与托尔金的方式几乎如出一辙。正是在这种情况下，他在空袭中遇到了一种幽灵般的 figura。接着艾略特写道：在那面目全非的街道上，他向我道别，随后伴随着号角声消散。
horn. And this kind of conjures up the dawn after an air raid. And in Lord of the Rings, you get this very, very famous moment where Gandalf is confronting the Lord of the Nazgul, the Witch King on his pterodactyl. So a bit like the Nazgul has descended a bit like a kind of German bomber over London. And then suddenly, in the distance, they hear horns wildly blowing. So it's exactly the same thing. The blowing of the horn and the blowing of the horn ends the air raid. Dawn comes, light comes. Rohan had come at last. Rohan had come at last.
这有点让人联想到空袭过后的黎明。而在《魔戒》中，你会看到这样一个非常、非常著名的时刻：甘道夫正在对抗戒灵之王、骑着翼手龙的巫王。这有点像戒灵降临，就像一架德国轰炸机飞过伦敦上空一样。然后突然间，他们在远处听到号角狂吹。所以这完全是一回事。号角声响起，号角声结束了空袭。黎明降临，光明到来。洛汗最终还是赶到了。洛汗最终还是赶到了。
So the echo of little Gidding is, I think, very clear. So Eliot and Tolkien both knew this guy, Charles Williams, who was a kind of very mystical Christian of the kind that would exactly appeal to both Eliot and Tolkien. And I wonder if there's some, you know, I don't know if Tolkien read Eliot, but that sense of air raid wardens, of danger from the sky, of the way in which it gets framed in kind of Christian mythology. It's a very, very strange inimitable mix, but both Eliot and Tolkien are doing it. And they're doing it in a way that I think speaks incredibly profoundly to people who may not be remotely Christian or may not be remotely interested in any of the kind of the paraphernalia, the mythic paraphernalia that the two men are respectively drawing on. Whether in poetry or in prose,
所以，我认为《小吉丁》的回响非常清晰。因此，艾略特和托尔金都认识这个人，查尔斯·威廉姆斯，他是一位非常神秘的基督徒，正是那种绝对会吸引艾略特和托尔金的人。我想知道是否有什么，你知道的，我不知道托尔金是否读过艾略特，但那种关于空袭民防员、来自天空的危险、以及它被框定在某种基督教神话中的方式。这是一种非常、非常奇怪、独一无二的混合体，但艾略特和托尔金都在这么做。而且他们这样做的方式，我认为深深地打动了那些可能根本不是基督徒、或者可能对这两人各自借鉴的神话用具完全不感兴趣的人。无论是在诗歌还是散文中，
Eliot and Tolkien are both kind of onto something that people clearly, not just in Britain, but around the world find incredibly powerful and moving. And I think it is that kind of fusion of Christian mythic ideas with a hardly one sense of not exactly victory over the horrors of the age, but a sense that they can at least be faced, that you can look into their face. And I think that's the power of it. Tom, before we start this podcast, I think Tolkien skeptics and Rest is History skeptics
艾略特和托尔金都触及了某种人们——不仅在英国，而且在全世界——觉得无比强大和感人的东西。我认为，这正是基督教神话理念与一种对那个时代的恐怖说不上是战胜、但至少是能够直面它们的感受的融合，那种你可以直面它们的勇气。我想这就是它的力量所在。汤姆，在我们开始这个播客之前，我认为托尔金怀疑论者和《历史的其余部分》怀疑论者
would have expected us to talk about three things. They'd have expected the appearance of Stanley Baldwin. They'd have expected you to dissect the air defenses of Mordor. And they'd have expected Christian mythic ideas. And we've given them all three, and dinosaurs in the first half. So in the second half, I think we should talk a little bit about Tolkien's politics, which I think are really interesting. I think The Lord of the Rings is a political book, and race, because this, of course, is something that the Amazon series has very visibly tried to change and that Tolkien and his relationship with race is something that for his critics is now, I think, probably item number one on the charge
本会期待我们讨论三件事。他们本会期待斯坦利·鲍德温的出场；他们本会期待你剖析魔多的防空系统；他们本会期待基督教神话理念。而这三点我们都讲了，前半部分甚至还讲了恐龙。所以在后半部分，我认为我们应该谈谈托尔金的政治观，我认为这非常有趣。我认为《魔戒》是一本政治书籍，还有种族问题，因为这当然是亚马逊剧集非常明显试图改变的事情，而且托尔金及其与种族的关系，对他的批评者来说，现在可能已经是罪状清单上的头号大项了。
sheet. And we will be discussing that after the break. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我们将会在中场休息后讨论这个。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. It was one of the saddest hours in their lives. The great chimney rose up before them. And as they drew near the old village across the water, through rows of new mean houses along each side of the road, they saw the new mill in all its frowning and dirty ugliness, a great brick building straddling the stream, which it fouled with a steaming and stinking outflow. All along the bywater road, every tree had been felled. That is from a chapter called The Scouring of the Shire in Lord of the Rings, and it describes the return of the hobbits from their great quest back to the shire this um vision of edwardian rural
如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及抢先购买现场活动门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这是他们一生中最悲伤的时刻之一。巨大的烟囱在他们面前拔地而起。当他们靠近水边那个古老的村庄时，穿过路边一排排新建的、简陋的房屋，他们看到了那座崭新的磨坊，散发着令人厌恶的肮脏与丑陋，那是一座巨大的砖砌建筑，横跨在溪流之上，用蒸汽和恶臭的污水污染了水源。沿着拜沃特路，所有的树都被砍倒了。这段话出自《魔戒》中名为“夏尔的光复”一章，它描述了霍比特人结束伟大征程返回夏尔的景象——这番爱德华世俗时期的乡村
england to discover dominic yeah the house builders have been at work yes so there are a little developers have been in yeah that's right yes um so this is that now this is a chapter this is one of the last chapters of the book it's it's almost entirely missing well pretty much entirely missing from the film versions because the director of the films, Peter Jackson, said that he didn't really know what to do with it, and he felt it was jarring. And I think that's such an interesting choice that he made. I think it's the wrong choice, because to me, this is one of the elements of the book that clearly lifts it above the high Victorian fantasy adventure quest model that Tolkien had clearly had in mind somehow
英格兰景象，多米尼克，是的，筑路工已经开始大兴土木了，是的，所以有一些小开发商已经介入了，是的，没错，是的，嗯，所以这是，现在这是书中的一个章节，这是书中的最后几章节之一，它在电影版本中几乎完全缺失了，嗯，基本上可以说是完全缺失，因为电影导演彼得·杰克逊说他真的不知道该拿它怎么办，他觉得这很突兀。我认为他做出的这个选择太有趣了。我认为这是一个错误的决定，因为对我来说，这是书中明确将其提升到高维多利亚时期奇幻冒险征程模式之上的元素之一，而这种模式自托尔金还是个男孩时起，就显然在某种程度上铭刻在他心中了。
since he was a boy. So again, one of the common things that Tolkien's critics say is, well, it's just a sort of trite childish story of good versus evil. The baddies are defeated, good triumphs, hurrah, hurrah. And this is fit for infants and adolescents. I think this chapter completely gives the light of that. So clearly at some level, there's a First World War thing going on here. So famously, David Lloyd George, not a friend of the rest of his history, had promised Britain's servicemen that they would return to home as fit for heroes. actually, they returned to a very gray, miserable decade, the 1920s in Britain, not the roaring 20s at all, an age of high unemployment
所以再次回到托尔金的批评者们常说的一个观点，那就是，这只是一种陈腐的、属于儿童的好人与坏人之争的故事。坏人被击败，正义获胜，万岁，万岁。这只适合幼儿和青少年。我认为这一章完全驳斥了这种说法。所以很显然，在某种层面上，这里面有第一次世界大战的影子。众所周知，大卫·劳埃德·乔治——他可不是《历史的其余部分》的朋友——曾向英国的军人们承诺，他们回国后将享受英雄般的待遇。实际上，他们回到了一个非常灰暗、悲惨的十年，即20世纪20年代的英国，一点也不是什么喧嚣的20年代，那是一个高失业率
and homelessness and injured servicemen begging on street corners and so on and so forth. So there's an element of that about it, I think. The returning veteran, I mean, it's a bit like, you know, Vietnam veterans returning in the 1970s to America, the returning veteran who sort of feels miserable. But also, I mean, I think this absolutely cuts to the heart of Tolkien's political and religious and kind of cultural vision. banal and humdrum way their cherished bit of england as it were has changed it has become more modern it's become more industrial there are as you as you described in that brilliant passage there are chimneys and factories so in other words serhole has become birmingham yeah um in the scramble has moved in right the cadbury's manufacturers uh have set up shop. But also, I think there are clearly an obviously ideological political dimension. Gerald Tolkien was very conservative. I mean, he was insanely conservative.
、无家可归、受伤的军人在街头乞讨等等的时代。所以我觉得这里面有这方面的成分。归来的退伍军人，我的意思是，这有点像，你知道的，20世纪70年代归国的美国越战老兵，那种感到生活悲惨的归国退伍军人。但同时，我的意思是，我认为这绝对触及了托尔金的政治、宗教以及某种文化愿景的核心。他们所珍视的那片英格兰，以一种陈旧而平庸的方式，发生了改变，变得更加现代，变得更加工业化，正如你刚才在那段精彩的段落中所描述的那样，那里有了烟囱和工厂。换句话说，萨尔霍尔变成了伯明翰，嗯，激烈的争夺已经介入，没错，吉百利制造商，呃，已经开业了。但同时，我认为这里显然也有一个意识形态上的政治维度。杰拉尔德·托尔金非常保守。我的意思是，他保守得无以复加。
Insofar as he must have voted, because most people did vote, and I imagine he would have seen it as his civic duty. I think it's almost impossible to imagine him voting anything other than he would have voted, I think, grudgingly for the Conservatives. But, I mean, Dominic, Stanley Baldwin's great. He was a great builder, wasn't he? Great house builder. But Stanley Baldwin, of course, never went on a quest. I think this is the issue.
就他可能参与投票而言——因为大多数人都投票了，而且我想他会把这视为自己的公民义务。我认为几乎不可能想象他会投别的票，我想他大概会很不情愿地投给保守党。但是，多米尼克，斯坦利·鲍德温很伟大。他是个伟大的建设者，不是吗？伟大的房屋建造者。但斯坦利·鲍德温当然从未踏上过征途。我想这就是问题所在。
I suppose. So Stanley Baldwin is Bilbo in chapter one, but not subsequent chapters. But they're coming back and they're seeing all these houses being built. Well, they don't like the houses. They don't like the houses. But I think a lot of, I mean, so the Scouring of the Shire is written, that chapter is written, I think, after the end of the Second World War. So under the Attlee government. Under the Attlee government.
我想是的。所以斯坦利·鲍德温是第一章里的比尔博，但不是后续章节里的。但他们回来后，看到这些建造的房屋。嗯，他们不喜欢这些房屋。他们不喜欢这些房屋。但我想很多人，我的意思是，所以“夏尔的光复”这一章是在第二次世界大战结束后才写的，是在艾德礼政府时期。在艾德礼政府时期。
Now, some people, you know, Tolkien bitterly resisted any claims that there was any kind of allegory. He said, I don't like allegories. The Lord of the Rings is not an allegory. And I think it's not meant to be an allegory for the Attlee government. But as with the climate of the 1930s, it's hard to believe that the headlines and the cultural conversation in the late 1940s didn't influence what he's writing. So to give you some examples, the shire is now under the command of a chief who sends out gatherers and sharers who go around, we're told, counting and measuring and taking things off to storage so that the farmers don't see their own products again. The inns have been closed because the chief doesn't hold with
现在，有些人，你知道的，托尔金强烈反对任何声称其中存在某种寓言的说法。他说，我讨厌寓言。《魔戒》不是寓言。我认为它并非旨在成为艾德礼政府的寓言。但正如20世纪30年代的氛围一样，很难相信20世纪40年代末的头条新闻和文化讨论没有影响他的创作。举几个例子，夏尔现在由一个长官统治，他会派出去收集者和分发者，据我们所知，他们四处进行清点和测量，把东西搬进仓库，这样农民就再也看不到自己的农产品了。酒馆被关闭了，因为长官不赞成
beer. I mean, that sounds very much like a kind of early 20th century conservatives' complaint that do-gooding liberals and interfering bossy Labour politicians are closing all the pubs. And the authorities have recruited hundreds of policemen, and they're called sheriffs, who we're told like minding other folks' business and talking big. And if any of us small folks stand up for our rights, they drag him off to the lockholes, to the prison, and so on.
喝啤酒。我的意思是，这听起来非常像20世纪初保守派的抱怨，认为那些好管闲事的自由派和干涉成性的工会政客正在关掉所有的酒吧。当局还招募了数百名警察，他们被称为治安官，据我们所知，他们喜欢管别人的闲事，说话还趾高气扬。如果我们这些小民中的任何人站出来捍卫自己的权利，他们就会把他拖进锁洞监狱里，诸如此类。
So all of this is a portrait of a world in which of surveillance, of ration books, of interference, of big government, of people building council houses, of a sort of an anti-conservative administration. Now, again, I don't think Tolkien means it deliberately as an attack on the Atlee government. I don't think he would do anything so simplistic. But I think there is a sense in which this is – he described himself once as a sort of conservative anarchist.
所以所有这些都是对这样一个世界的描绘：一个充满监控、配给券、干涉、大政府、人们建造公屋、充满反保守派行政作风的世界。现在，再次申明，我不认为托尔金是有意将其作为对艾德礼政府的攻击。我不认为他会做如此简单化的事。但我认为某种程度上这就是——他曾把自己描述为一种保守的无政府主义者。
And I think that's exactly what this is. It says, leave us alone, don't interfere. But it's also, I think that pessimism, that gloom, you know, because we've been led to believe that the hobbits are the incarnation of Englishness and of good heart, stout-hearted Englishness. And yet it turns out lots of them are happy to collaborate with the new regime.
而我认为这正是它的写照。它说的是，别管我们，不要干涉。但这也包含着那种悲观主义，那种阴郁，（你知道的，因为我们一直被灌输一种观念，即霍比特人是英格兰精神和善良心地、坚韧不拔的英格兰精神的化身）。然而结果证明，他们当中有许多人乐于与新政权合作。
Lots of them are happy to inform. We're told that they have lost the will to fight, that they've shrunk inside their own homes. So it's very down. It's very grey. It's very down. But you can understand why Peter Jackson didn't want to put it in his Hollywood movies. But I think the fact that he didn't suggest to me that he misunderstood what Tolkien was
许多人乐于告密。我们被告知，他们失去了战斗的意志，在自己的家中畏缩不前。所以这非常令人沮丧。非常灰暗。非常令人沮丧。但你可以理解为什么彼得·杰克逊不想把它拍进他的好莱坞电影里。不过我认为他没有这么做，这表明他误解了托尔金想要达到的目的
trying to achieve. I mean, it appears very fleetingly as a kind of glimpse of the future. But in that future, as I remember, it's the orcs who are doing it and not the hobbits. Because the point is, it's the hobbits themselves that are doing most of the heavy lifting in this sort of new regime. So, I mean, when you say that Tolkien is conservative, I mean, I don't think that adequately expresses. I mean, he's not an enthusiast for democracy, for instance. because of all his obsession with kingship for example he he's i mean he's literally in favor of a sacral kingship i and so this is what aragorn becomes this kind of king arthur figure in lord of the rings this
我的意思是，它只是非常短暂地作为对未来的惊鸿一瞥出现过。但在那个未来，如果我没记错的话，是兽人在做这些事，而不是霍比特人。因为重点在于，正是霍比特人自己在这个所谓的新政权中挑起了最重的大梁。所以，我的意思是，当你认为托尔金是保守的时，我的意思是，我认为这并没有充分表达出来。我的意思是，他不是民主的热情拥护者，比如说。因为他痴迷于君主制，例如，他——我的意思是，他字面意义上支持神圣君主制。所以这就是阿拉贡最终变成的角色，在《魔戒》中这种亚瑟王似的人物，这
is basically tolkien's what you know that there should genuinely be a some king with a magic sword that will yeah in everything will be harrah for the king with the magic sword. And I think he kind of believes that in the same way that he thinks that Ells once really walked, you know, England's green and pleasant land. He doesn't, he doesn't believe it, you mean? He doesn't, he doesn't believe it. But, but I mean, clearly he, I mean, he is massively, massively not of the left. He's, I mean,
基本上就是托尔金的——你知道的，应该真地存在一个拥有魔法宝剑的国王，然后一切都会为拥有魔法宝剑的国王万岁。而且我认为他某种程度上相信这一点，就像他认为精灵真的曾在英格兰青山绿水中漫步一样。他不是——他不是真的相信，你是这个意思吗？他不是——他不是真的相信。但是，但是我的意思是，显然他——我的意思是，他在极大地、极大地不属于左翼。我的意思是，
he's so reactionary that basically his, his vision of the ideal form of government is 6-3-7 or something. But I think that another aspect of that passage that I read where the trees are chopped down to make ways for houses, it's a reminder of just how conservative what we would now call the Green movement was for most of the 20th century. So today, by and large, green causes are associated with the left. So there's the kind of the watermelon is the accusation from people on the right that you're green on the surface and red in the heart. Purist red deep down but actually one of the many ways in which lord of the rings is very very much the novel of the 20th century is is that tolkien is way ahead of anxieties about
他极其反动，以至于基本上他的理想政府形式是6-3-7之类的。但我认为，我读的那段关于为了盖房子而砍伐树木的段落还有另一个方面，它提醒我们，我们现在所说的绿色运动在整个20世纪的大部分时间里是多么的保守。所以今天，总的来说，绿色事业与左翼联系在一起。因此，右翼人士有一种指控，即“西瓜”，意思是表面是绿的，内心是红的。内心深处是纯粹的红，但实际上，《魔戒》之所以非常非常成为20世纪的小说，其众多方式之一就是，托尔金远远走在了对
where the environment is going um and his yes his association more tom to the degree that basically he's against the industrial revolution i mean wholesale yeah lots of kind of radical greed you know radical greens on the left today would be who would say you know it's it's the whole problem is industrial civilization and capitalism we need to get rid of it i mean tolkien would wholeheartedly agree but his solution would be that we go back and have a kind of communitarian um existence we go back and we have a king with a magic sword but basically yeah bring back the feudal system. Again and again and again throughout Lord of the Rings, industry, the destruction of trees,
环境走向的担忧的前面，嗯，还有他的，是的，他更倾向于反对工业化，汤姆，基本上就是反对工业革命，也就是全面反对，嗯。许多当今左翼的激进环保主义者会说，你知道的，整个问题在于工业文明和资本主义，我们需要摆脱它。我的意思是，托尔金会完全同意，但他的解决方案是，我们倒退回去，过一种群居的、嗯，存在方式，我们倒退回去，拥有一个拿着魔法宝剑的国王，但基本上——是的，把封建制度带回来。在《魔戒》中，一次又一次，工业，对树木的破坏——
he loves trees with, again, a kind of mystical sense. The wizard who is, again, I'm giving away spoilers here, but who turns out to be behind the scouring of the Shire. He's obsessed with technology. He destroys trees, he burns them, he turns what had previously been clean flowing rivers into slurry tips. They're very like the water companies at the moment. We're told he loves wheels and contraptions and all these kinds of things. But also, again, a very kind of a prefiguring of modern anxieties. He breeds this kind of terrifying race of monsters. He's kind of experimenting with what we would now call genetics, I suppose, even though genetics hadn't been developed at that point. So he's such a paradoxical figure that he's so reactionary.
他热爱树木，同样带有一种神秘感。那个巫师——在这里我又剧透了——结果发现他才是夏尔光复背后的黑手。他沉迷于科技，他毁坏树木，焚烧树木，把以前清澈流淌的河流变成泥浆场。他们现在看起来很像水务公司。我们被告知他喜欢齿轮、小发明和所有这类东西。但同样，这也非常像是对现代焦虑的一种预示。他培育了这种可怕的怪物种族。他在尝试我们现在所说的基因学，我想，尽管当时基因学还没有发展起来。所以他是一个如此矛盾的人物，他如此反动。
He's so reactionary. And yet in so many ways, he's so progressive. Well, that's obviously why his books. Yes, why hippies come to love them, why the counterculture in the 60s come to love them. Yeah. So that's an interesting story in itself, Tom, because his books were,
他如此反动。然而在很多方面，他又如此进步。嗯，这显然就是为什么他的书籍——是的，为什么嬉皮士会爱上它们，为什么60年代的反文化会爱上它们。是的。所以这本身就是一个有趣的故事，汤姆，因为他的书籍——
they weren't massively successful in America until somebody printed a pirate edition in 1965. Is that the one with two emus on the cover? I think it's something like that. A Christmas tree and two emus. He asked, why have you done that? And he said, I've never read it. No, I think it's something like that had a christmas tree and two emus he asked why have you done that and he said and he said i've never read it now i think that's actually a british i think that's the first british edition had had exactly that but no the american version ace books did in 1965 it was a complete rip-off because they claimed that the tolkien had no
在1965年有人出版盗版书之前，它们在美国并没有取得巨大成功。那是封面上有两只鸸鹋的那本吗？我想差不多是那样吧。一棵圣诞树和两只鸸鹋。他问，你为什么这么做？他说，我从来没读过。不，我想差不多是那样的，有一棵圣诞树和两只鸸鹋，他问，你为什么这么做？他说——他说我从来没读过。现在，我认为这其实是英国——我想那是第一本英国版，正好有那个。不，美国版本是1965年Ace出版社出版的，那完全是一个盗版，因为他们声称托尔金在美利坚没有
copyright in america he then produced a new edition for america that he did have copyright on and of course that comes out at precisely the moment when there's a huge appetite for kind of countercultural stuff. So the Vietnam War is in full swing. The hippie movement has taken off. People start wearing these badges that say Frodo lives, Gandalf the president. Tolkien is hobbit forming. So this is, yeah, Tolkien is hobbit forming.
版权。他随后为美国出版了一个拥有版权的新版本。当然，那个版本出版的时刻，恰好人们对反文化的东西有着巨大的渴望。所以越战正酣。嬉皮士运动兴起。人们开始佩戴写着“弗罗多活着”、“甘道夫当总统”的徽章。托尔金正在塑造霍比特人。所以这是——是的，托尔金正在塑造霍比特人。
So this is Richard Nixon's America. And Tolkien takes off and he is seen as a Bible for countercultural, small is beautiful, you know, the green movements, the age of limits. And that, in a way, I mean, that's still part of his appeal, I think, particularly to sort of to countercultural people who might be otherwise uncomfortable with some of his politics. But what is the, I mean, you mentioned about the wizard Saruman breeding these creatures, these monsters. And of course, that raises a question that is not one that people posed to, or people addressed to Tolkien's work 20 or 30 years ago, but they certainly do now, which is about Tolkien and race. Because you see quite often now, critics, particularly in America, who will say, Tolkien, by pitting hobbits, men, elves, dwarves against this race of monsters called orcs,
所以这是理查德·尼克森的美国。托尔金大受欢迎，他被视为反文化、《小的是美好的》、绿色运动、极限时代的一本圣经。在某种程度上，这——我认为这仍然是他吸引力的一部分，特别是对那些可能对他的某些政治观点感到不适的反文化人士而言。但是，你的意思是——你提到巫师萨鲁曼培育这些生物、这些怪物。当然，这引发了一个问题，这不是30或40年前人们向托尔金提出或向托尔金的作品探讨的问题，但现在他们肯定会这么问了，那就是关于托尔金和种族的问题。因为你现在经常看到批评家，特别是在美国，他们会说，托尔金通过让霍比特人、人类、精灵、矮人与这个被称为兽人的怪物种族对抗，
he has basically created a racist work that racial assumptions permeate the Lord of the Rings, that it is the North and the West are good, the East and the South are bad, all of this kind of business. Tom, what do you think about all that? Do you think there's some truth in that? I think there's no question that, I mean, I said at the beginning of the first episode we did that I think Tolkien's influence on how the Middle Ages is seen is absolutely fundamental at the most popular level and i think that idea of kind of white white skinned golden haired kings with magical swords fighting black hordes of orcs is crucial part of what animates a sense that the study of the Middle Ages is inherently racist or has a huge problem with racism. So this is a big thing in American younger academics who now
他基本上创造了一部种族主义作品，种族假设渗透在《魔戒》中，即北方和西方是好的，东方和南方是坏的，诸如此类的事情。汤姆，你怎么看这一切？你认为其中有一些真相吗？我认为毫无疑问——我在我们做的第一集开头就说过，我认为托尔金对中世纪观感的影响在最受欢迎的层面上是绝对根本性的，而且我认为那种白皮肤、金发、手持魔法宝剑的国王与兽人黑色大军战斗的观念，是激发人们认为中世纪研究本身带有种族主义或存在严重种族主义问题这一感觉的关键部分。所以这是美国年轻学者中的一个大问题，他们现在
say the whole field of medieval studies is permeated with white supremacy. I mean, I was only reading something about this at the weekend. The American Historical Association has been cancelled in recent days, Tom. So this is a huge issue, particularly in the United States. And I think that Tolkien is a man of his time. Well, he's not even a man of his time. I mean, he's a man who's reactionary even by the standards of the 30s and 40s. So I don't think that if Lord of the Rings was published now, I think that sensitivity readers would not really let quite large elements of it go through. So I don't think that if Lord of the Rings was published now, I think that sensitivity readers would not really let quite large elements of it go through. So I don't think that they would allow orcs to be described as black-skinned, which-
声称整个中世纪研究领域都充斥着白人至上主义。我的意思是，我周末刚读到关于这方面的内容。美国历史协会最近几天都被取消文化了，汤姆。所以这是一个巨大的问题，尤其是在美国。而且我认为托尔金是一个时代的人。嗯，他甚至不是一个时代的人。我的意思是，即使按照30和40年代的标准，他也是一个反动的人。所以我不认为如果《魔戒》现在出版的话，敏感度读者不会真的放过其中相当大的部分。所以我不认为如果《魔戒》现在出版的话，敏感度读者不会真的放过其中相当大的部分。所以我不认为他们会允许兽人被描述为黑皮肤，这——
Or swarthy, for example, is the kind of word that- Kingdoms of men who ally themselves with Sauron, the Dark Lord, are clearly modelled on Arabs and Ethiopians and people from the Deep South. And that's pretty clear from Tolkien's own writings that he's drawing on that. The dwarves are pretty clearly, there are echoes of how medieval Christians saw the Jews in them. The draw, interestingly, in The Hobbit, lost their homeland. Lost their homeland. There are 12 of them, like the tribes of Israel. Their language is loosely based on Hebrew. So I think that Tolkien is using, well, it's not so much modern categories of race, but medieval categories of difference.
或者比如说，皮肤黝黑，这是那种词——与黑暗魔王索伦结盟的人类王国，显然是以阿拉伯人和埃塞俄比亚人以及来自远南方的人为原型的。从托尔金自己的著作中可以很清楚地看出，他在借鉴这些。矮人也相当明显，其中有中世纪基督徒如何看待犹太人的回响。有趣的是，《霍比特人》中的矮人失去了家园。失去了家园。他们有12个人，就像以色列的部落。他们的语言大致基于希伯来语。所以我觉得托尔金使用的是——与其说是现代的种族范畴，不如说是中世纪的差异范畴。
So in a way that I think people would find awkward now. But I think that Tolkien is reactionary because essentially his prejudices, attacking the city, the great city, the shining city, this city that is a capital of a long fall, all that remains of a once great empire. I think he's very consciously evoking echoes of the Arab sieges of Constantinople, or the Hungarian sieges of the siege of Augsburg that gets foiled by Otto the Great with his great cavalry charge and all that kind of thing and I think he's doing that partly because these are the echoes that move him they're bread of his reading but I think also because he's he's situated in a world where there really aren't that many Arabs living in Oxford so he doesn't really ever come come across them. So he's thinking of them as people who are kind of remote. I think it wouldn't occur to him in a million years that an Arabic reader
因此，以一种我认为人们现在会觉得尴尬的方式。但我认为托尔金是反动的，因为本质上他的偏见——攻击城市，伟大的城市，闪耀的城市，这个曾经伟大帝国的最后遗迹、曾经陷落的首都。我认为他非常刻意地唤起人们对阿拉伯人围攻君士坦丁堡，或者匈牙利人围攻奥格斯堡的记忆，奥格斯堡的围困被大奥托以其伟大的骑兵冲锋等方式化解了，我认为他这么做部分是因为这些是打动他的回响，它们是他阅读的养分，但我也认为是因为他所处的环境中，牛津并没有那么多阿拉伯人，所以他实际上从未真正遇到过他们。因此，他把他们视为一种遥远的人。我想他有一百万年也不会想到会有一个阿拉伯读者
would ever come across it. And you may feel that that's kind of special pleading for him, but I think that you can see what he's doing with the medieval stereotypes with what he does with the Jews. And he did know Jews. So when he's an air raid warden, his fellow air raid warden for a lot of that time is a Jewish scholar with whom they get on very well. And Tolkien was a great admirer of the Jews. He's asked when his book is published in Germany, he needs to fill in a form about whether or not he's of Aryan stock. Now he writes one letter where he says he's really offended by being asked if he's of Aryan stock. He doesn't really recognize the category. And then he writes another letter, I think, where he's asked if he's got Jewish
会读到它。你可能会觉得这是在为他诡辩，但我认为你可以看出他在用中世纪的刻板印象对付犹太人时做了什么。而且他确实认识犹太人。所以当他担任空袭民防员时，在很长一段时间里，他的同伴是一个犹太学者，他们相处得非常好。托尔金非常崇拜犹太人。当他的书在德国出版时，他被要求填写一份关于他是否具有雅利安血统的表格。现在他写了一封信，说他对被问及是否具有雅利安血统感到非常冒犯。他并不真正承认这个范畴。然后我想他又写了另一封信，被问及他是否有犹太
antecedents. And he says, I mean, to cut a very long story short, he basically says, I wish I did. I'd be very happy if I did. Yeah. So he gets asked if Tolkien is a Jewish name and he says, it is not Jewish in origin, though I should consider it an honor if it were. And also he was very hostile to the way that Wagner portrayed Jews in The Ring Cycle. He hated The Ring Cycle. He hated everything to do with Wagner. And I think that there is a very conscious element within his portrayal of the dwarves who go on the mission to get back, the Lonely Man, to get their kingdom back from the dragon. I think there is a kind of echo there. I mean, so he actually said in an interview,
血统。他说——长话短说，他基本上说，我希望我有。如果我有，我会很高兴。是的。所以有人问托尔金是不是一个犹太姓氏，他说，它在起源上不是犹太姓氏，不过如果它是的话，我会认为这是一种荣誉。而且他对瓦格纳在《尼伯龙根的指环》中描绘犹太人的方式非常敌视。他讨厌《指环》。他讨厌与瓦格纳有关的一切。而且我认为，在他对矮人的描绘中有一个非常刻意的元素，这些矮人踏上了夺回“孤山”、从恶龙手中夺回他们王国的使命。我认为那里有一种回响。我的意思是，他实际上在一次采访中说过——
so 1962, I think, 1963, something like that, that I do think of the dwarves like Jews, at once native and alien in the habitation, speaking the languages of the country, but with an accent due to their own private tongue. So no author today would ever frame it in those terms. But equally, Tom, I don't think you would look at that and say those are the words of a vicious anti-Semite, would you? I mean, you wouldn't remotely say that. No, they're not. So Tolkien is basically recalibrating medieval negative stereotypes
所以是1962年，我想，1963年左右，诸如此类——我确实把矮人看作犹太人，他们在居住地既是本地人又是异乡人，说着当地国家的语言，但带有他们自己私下语言的口音。所以今天没有任何一个作家会用这些词来构架它。但同样，汤姆，我想你不会看到这一点并说这是一个恶毒的反犹主义者的言论，对吧？我的意思是，你绝不会这么说。不，它们不是。所以托尔金基本上是在重构中世纪对犹太人的负面刻板印象，
of Jews in a way that he sees as heroic. And he is, in doing that, he's doing what he always does, which is he draws on the legacy of old English poetry. So he translated a book called Exodus, which portrays Moses as a great warrior. And so that's what he's doing with the dwarves. He's portraying Jews that are medieval, that are integrated with the Northern myth. So he gives the dwarves in The Hobbit Nordic names. So he's fusing them, which is, and you see the same thing with Minas Tirith, which is this city that is clearly based loosely on Constantinople. It's a kind of Rome that never falls. But he also compares that to the people who live there as having the clear purity of Jewish monotheism, he says. So
将其转化为他所认为的英雄主义。在这样做的过程中，他做着他一贯在做的事，那就是他借鉴了古英语诗歌的遗产。所以他翻译了一本名为《出埃及记》的书，将摩西描绘成一个伟大的勇士。这就是他对矮人所做的事。他把犹太人描绘成中世纪的、与北方神话融为一体的形象。所以他在《霍比特人》中给矮人起了北欧名字。所以他将它们融合在一起，而且你在米纳斯提力斯身上也能看到同样的情况，这座城市显然大致取材于君士坦丁堡。它是一个永不陷落的罗马。但他也将居住在那里的人比作具有犹太一神教清晰纯洁性的人，他说。所以
he's fusing there the Roman and the Jewish. So he's fusing these elements that are often not fused in a way that suggests to me that he absolutely was not anti-Semitic. I was going to say everything we know from his writings more generally, Tom, is that he's not somebody who by the standards of mid-century britain wears prejudice heavily i mean he he everything we know about him so he writes to his son and says how much he deplores um the the racial system in south africa for example in his native south africa he there's also other elements so for example it's sometimes said well his books are all about whiteness. And that's actually not quite right. I mean, there was a character who we've already mentioned called Saruman the White, who is the very embodiment
他在那里将罗马和犹太融合在一起。因此，他融合了这些通常不会融合的元素，这向我表明他绝对不是反犹太主义者。我本来要说的是，汤姆，我们从他的更广泛著作中所了解到的关于他的一切，都表明他不是那种按世纪中叶英国标准会带有沉重偏见的人——我的意思是，他——我们关于他的一切了解，比如他写信给他的儿子，说他多么谴责南非的种族制度，例如在他故乡南非。这里还有其他元素——例如，有时有人说，好吧，他的书籍全都是关于白人至上的。而这其实并不完全正确。我的意思是，有一个我们已经提到过的角色叫白袍萨鲁曼，他正是白人至上的化身，
of whiteness, who actually turns out to be the most dreadful Taurac. Similarly, you mentioned the thing about the armies who end up allied with the baddies um are dark-skinned they're from the south and all this but there's a very telling moment when one of the heroes sees one of them and he's dead and he looks at him and he feels sorry for him and he thinks he's a man just like me you know well he's not a man because the heroes are hobbits but he's a he's a he's a person of you know dignity and whatever yeah but what's just like me you know, dignity and whatever. Yeah. Just like me.
而他最后却成了最可怕的暴君。同样，你提到那些最终与坏人结盟的军队是皮肤黝黑的，他们来自南方诸如此类，但有一个非常说明问题的时刻，其中一个英雄看到了他们中的一个人，他死了，他看着他，为他感到难过，他想他就像我一样的人，你知道的——好吧，他不是人，因为英雄是霍比特人，但他是一个有尊严的人，无论如何，是的。但什么就像我一样，你知道的，有尊严什么的。是的。就像我一样。
What's his story? What's his story? What has brought him here? How tragic that he's lying dead and all this sort of thing. And I think also the other element that people often talk about with Tolkien, Tolkien juxtaposes light and shadow. He talks about the darkness, the dark lord, the black speech, all of those kinds of things. And people say, oh, golly, this is imperialism and white supremacy and stuff. I think that's completely wrong. Those things are all there in the Norse myths, the idea of shadow versus light,
他的故事是什么？他的故事是什么？是什么把他带到这里的？他躺在那里死去是多么悲惨，诸如此类。而且我认为人们经常谈论的托尔金的另一个元素是，托尔金将光明与阴影并置。他谈论黑暗、黑暗魔王、黑暗语，所有这些东西。人们说，噢，天哪，这是帝国主义和白人至上主义之类的东西。我认为这完全是错误的。这些东西在北欧神话中都存在，关于阴影与光明的对立，
and they're all there in the Bible. So Tolkien's great favourite saint was, you know, his name, John. So Saint John, who writes about, you know, the light coming into the darkness. And that sense of light is very, very strong throughout Lord of the Rings. It's theologically bred. Tolkien had no interest, I think, in real interest in racial politics in the way that it would be understood now. No, I'm sure that's right. And he's writing it before that becomes a kind of current issue.
并且在圣经中也随处可见。所以托尔金最喜欢的圣徒是——你知道他的名字——约翰。所以圣约翰，他写到（你知道的）光明照进黑暗。那种对光明的感受在整个《魔戒》中非常、非常强烈。这是神学上孕育的。我认为托尔金对以现代方式理解的种族政治没有任何真正的兴趣。不，我确信那是对的。而且他在这种政治成为一种当前议题之前就已经写下了它。
But having said that, I mean, I do think that we talked about how Tolkien has no interest really in the German side. He identifies very strongly with this sense of being the progeny of generation after generation after generation of people who've lived in the Western Midlands, in Mercia. And that sense of identification with the West Midlands is so strong to him. So it's there in the portrayal of the Shire. The Shire is the West Midlands is so strong to him. So it's there in the portrayal of the Shire. The Shire is the West Midlands, it's Warwickshire, but it's also there in Rohan, which is this kingdom, which is clearly, it's not just an Anglo-Saxon kingdom, it's the Mercian kingdom. It's the kingdom, the Anglo-Saxon kingdom.
话虽如此，我的意思是，我确实认为我们讨论过托尔金对德国方面真的没有兴趣。他强烈地认同自己是一代又一代、一代又一代生活在西米德兰兹郡、麦西亚的人的后代。这种对西米德兰兹郡的认同感对他来说是如此强烈。所以它存在于对夏尔的描绘中。夏尔就是西米德兰兹郡，它对西米德兰兹郡是如此强烈。所以它存在于对夏尔的描绘中。夏尔就是西米德兰兹郡，它是沃里克郡，但它也存在于洛汗中，这个王国显然不仅是一个盎格鲁-萨克森王国，它就是麦西亚王国。它是那个王国，盎格鲁-萨克森王国。
It's Mercia if they had horses, basically, isn't it? So Mercia is the Latin for the mark and Rohan is called the mark. I mean, it really couldn't be clearer. Their emblem is a white horse on a green field. So that's drawing on the white horse of Uffington, which is on the side of this hill, this green field. The language that they speak corresponds not just to Old English, but to the Old English as spoken by the West Mercians. And you have this brilliant letter that Tolkien writes to his son where he's objecting basically to globalization. He's objecting to the way that everywhere is becoming the same. And he says, the bigger things get, the smaller and duller or flatter the globe gets. It is getting to be all one blasted little provincial suburb. And Tolkien's solution to this is that he is going to refuse to speak anything but old Mercian. So Tolkien's reaction to globalization is, let's speak old Mercian. So that sense of identification with this particular place, so the soil, or actually the air, he calls it. So as early as 1917, he's talking about the
基本上，如果麦西亚有马的话，它就是麦西亚，不是吗？所以“麦西亚”是拉丁语中“边界”的意思，而洛汗被称为“马克”（意为边界）。我的意思是，这真的不能再清楚了。他们的徽章是绿野白马。所以这是借鉴了乌芬顿白马，它位于这个山丘的山坡上，在一片绿草地上。他们说的语言不仅对应于古英语，而且对应于西麦西亚人所说的古英语。你有一封托尔金写给他儿子的精彩信件，他在信中基本上反对全球化。他反对各地变得千篇一律的方式。他说，事情越大，地球就变得越小、越沉闷或越扁平。它正在变成一个被炸毁的微小省级郊区。而托尔金对此的解决方案是，他将拒绝说除了古麦西亚语之外的任何语言。所以托尔金对全球化的反应是，让我们说古麦西亚语吧。所以这种对这个特定地方的认同感，即土地，或者实际上他称之为空气。早在1917年，他就谈到了
distinctive air. And interestingly, he counterpoints that with the Mediterranean world. So he's counterpointing the air of the North, so Scandinavia and Britain and Ireland, with the air of Roman Greece. But that's what's important to him. But I think it is possible to misinterpret that now. And it seems to me that if Tolkien is writing, you know, if his ambition was to write a mythology for England, it's important that that mythology, if it's to have any sense of some sense of being a mythology for England, that it should be a mythology for England as England is now, as well as it was in demented ambition, isn't it, to write a mythology for your own country when, as he sees, it doesn't exist. But I mean, by any standard, you would have to say he succeeded. Because The Lord of the Rings, you know, this project that would seem completely ludicrous to many writers in the 1930s and 1940s, and indeed got, you know, some considerable stick from early reviewers. That project turned out to be one of the most successful cultural projects of the 20th century. Completely, completely.
独特的空气。有趣的是，他将其与地中海世界进行对比。所以他将北方的空气（即斯堪的纳维亚、英国和爱尔兰）与罗马希腊的空气进行了对比。但这就是对很重要的事情。不过我认为现在还是有可能误解这一点的。在我看来，如果托尔金在写作——你知道的，如果他的雄心是为英格兰写一部神话，那么重要的是，这部神话如果要对英格兰有一点点神话的意义，它应该是一部属于当今英格兰的神话，就像它过去那样——这是一种疯狂的雄心，不是吗？当你看到他认为并不存在时，还要为自己的国家写一部神话。但我的意思是，按任何标准来看，你都得说他成功了。因为《魔戒》，你知道的，这个在20世纪30年代和40年代对许多作家来说似乎完全荒谬的项目，而且确实受到了早期评论家的一些相当大的批评。这个项目后来成为20世纪最成功的文化项目之一。完全是，完全是。
But wouldn't you agree that the risk is that this mythology for England that he created in the 40s, which kind of took wing in the 50s as immigration was happening into england that the risk is that because he's writing it at a time where basically everyone is white that there is a risk that that mythology becomes associated with a kind of england is for white people attitude um i don't think well i think the very fact of the amazon series so this new series which is the has given us the peg for our where they've they've made a deliberate attempt haven't they they've got black hobbits and well they've got lenny henry who is probably the most famous black west midlander yeah in england so that seems to
但难道你不认为风险在于，他在40年代为英格兰创造的这个神话，在50年代随着移民涌入英格兰而开始腾飞，风险在于，由于他是在每个人基本上都是白人的时期写作的，因此这种神话存在着与“英格兰属于白人”这种态度联系在一起的风险？嗯，我不认为——嗯，我认为亚马逊剧集的出现——这个为我们提供讨论由头的新系列，他们做出了刻意的尝试，不是吗？他们有黑人霍比特人和——嗯，他们有兰尼·亨利，他可能是英国最著名的西米德兰兹黑人，是的——所以这似乎
be entirely appropriate i mean it seems entirely with the grain of going with the grain of of everything that tolkien's ambitions would have been, I think. Well, people who are Tolkien critics, who defend Tolkien, sort of Tolkien scholars, will often say he created a world that was by definition multicultural. Yeah. And, you know, different languages. I mean, basically, the theme of The Lord of the Rings is different species, I guess, working together. Yeah, the three peoples.
完全合适，我的意思是，这似乎完全符合、顺应了托尔金雄心的所有方向，我认为。好吧，那些批评托尔金、为托尔金辩护的人——也就是托尔金学者，通常会说他创造了一个定义上就是多元文化的世界。是的。而且，你知道的，不同的语言。我的意思是，基本上，《魔戒》的主题就是不同的物种，我猜，在一起合作。是的，三个种族。
Yeah, absolutely. I mean, I think there's no doubt that Tolkien is a product of empire, that he's read Ryder Haggard, that he never questions these things. But why would he? I mean, most people don't in the 1930s and 1940s. It seems to me completely absurd to expect Tolkien to be a man of, I mean, he was barely even a man of the 20th century intellectually. I think the weird thing about him is the way in which, again and again, he's so reactionary that he ends up becoming almost by our standards progressive. It's kind of like... So the environmentalism.
是的，绝对的。我的意思是，我认为毫无疑问托尔金是帝国的产物，他读过莱德·哈格德，他从未质疑过这些事情。但为什么他要质疑呢？我的意思是，在20世纪30年代和40年代，大多数人都没有质疑。在我看来，期望托尔金成为一个——我的意思是，他在知识上甚至勉强算是一个20世纪的人，这完全是荒谬的。我认为关于他最奇怪的事情是，一次又一次，他如此反动，以至于按我们的标准来看，他最终几乎变得进步了。这有点像——所以环保主义。
Yeah, it's kind of like fascists ending up like communists. It's that same kind of weird, I suppose, like a ring, isn't it? Very nice image, Tom. Do you think, I mean, his book has proved enormously successful, far more successful than, so his critics said at first, I mean, they were saying in the 1970s, even in the 1980s, it will eventually be forgotten as merely a diversion for teenagers. That clearly, you know, has not worked out
是的，这有点像法西斯最终变成了共产主义。这大概就像一个环一样，不是很美妙的意象吗，汤姆？你认为——我的意思是，他的书已经证明了巨大的成功，远远超过了——所以他的批评者起初说，我的意思是，他们在70年代甚至80年代还在说，它最终会被遗忘，不过是青少年的消遣而已。那显然，你知道的，并没有成真。
because it's proved enormously successful. But do you think it will continue to be one of the books that people read and reread? Are people going to be reading it in the 22nd century? I'd have thought so, because there's clearly something about it that tugs you in. I mean, it's an incredibly well-told story, isn't it? Aside from anything else. It's an incredibly exciting adventure story with few parallels. Tom, I think it's fair to say that there's so many things we haven't talked about so we haven't talked about the streams of women we haven't talked about sam as our first world war batman uh we haven't talked about gollum as much as i was hoping to basically because we're
因为事实证明它取得了巨大的成功。但你认为它会继续成为人们反复阅读的书籍吗？人们在22世纪还会读它吗？我想会的，因为显然它有一种吸引你的力量。我的意思是，这是一个讲得极好的故事，不是吗？抛开其他不谈。这是一个无与伦比的、极其激动人心的冒险故事。汤姆，我觉得可以公平地说，有很多事情我们还没有谈到——我们没有谈到那些女性角色，我们没有谈到作为我们第一次世界大战随军作物的山姆，嗯，我们没有像我希望的那样多谈谈咕噜，基本上是因为我们
lord of the rings nerds and we could have uh bored on for hours couldn't we and we should confess at this stage that many years ago we had an ongoing marathon where we watched the extended editions of the films together with takeaways and our respective wives refused to join us. And that tells its own story, doesn't it? But on that bombshell, I think we should probably let, because we've been talking for over an hour,
是《指环王》的超级书迷，我们本可以聊上好几个小时，对吧？我们在这个阶段应该坦白，多年前我们曾举行过一次马拉松式的观看活动，我们一起看加长版的电影，吃着外卖，而我们的妻子们都拒绝加入我们。这说明了问题，不是吗？但带着这个重磅消息，我想我们大概应该让大家离开，因为我们已经聊了一个多小时了，
we should probably let people go about the rest of their lives. But, Tom, since we started with the beginning of The Hobbit, I think we should end with the end of The Lord of the Rings. Would you like me to give another of my nice readings? Yeah, like your Larkin. Like my Larkin, exactly. People were moved to tears by that. Or indeed, my readings from my own books, Adventures in Time,
我们大概应该让大家去过他们剩下的生活了。但是，汤姆，既然我们从《霍比特人》的开端开始，我想我们应该以《指环王》的结尾结束。你想让我再朗读一段我美妙的段落吗？是的，就像你读拉金那样。就像我读拉金一样，没错。人们曾为此感动得落泪。或者说，朗读我自己的书《时间历险记》中的片段，
which are available right now. And actually, J.R. tolkien is the opening character of my book about the first world war which if you have children or you know children or you've ever been a child i advise you to buy forthwith uh and of course he's also a key figure in your book chapter on the second world war dominion which i will say strongly recommend that you buy so jr tolkien was a great great believer in commercial self-promotion, wasn't he, Tom? He truly was.
这些书现在就可以买到。事实上，J.R.托尔金是我那本关于第一次世界大战的书中的开篇人物，如果你有孩子、认识孩子或者曾经是个孩子，我建议你马上买一本——当然，他也是你关于第二次世界大战的书《统治》中某一章的关键人物，我强烈建议大家购买。所以，J.R.托尔金非常非常相信商业自我宣传，对吧，汤姆？确实如此。
Well, he appeared in a calendar. Yes, he did. But he's sitting, he's fully encased in tweed, isn't he? He's not a Chippendales type. Sitting next to an oak. Stanley Baldwin type. Yes. He's dressed as Stanley Baldwin.
好吧，他出现在日历里。是的，他确实出现了。但他坐着，全身裹在粗花呢里，对吧？他可不是那种舞男类型的。坐在橡树旁边。斯坦利·鲍德温类型的人。是的。他打扮得像斯坦利·鲍德温。
Okay, here we go. At last the three companions turned away, and never again looking back they rode slowly homewards, and they spoke no word to one another until they came back to the shire, but each had great comfort in his friends on the long grey road. At last they rode over the downs and took the east road, and then Merry and Pippin rode on to Buckland, and already they were singing again as they went.
好了，我们开始吧。最后，三个同伴转过身去，再也没有回头，他们慢慢地骑马回家，一路上彼此无话，直到回到夏尔，但在漫长的灰暗道路上，每一个人都从同伴那里得到了巨大的慰藉。最后，他们骑马翻过丘陵，走上了东部大道，接着梅里和皮平骑马前往雄鹿地，一路上他们又唱起了歌。
But Sam turned to buy water, and so he came back up the hill as day was ending once more. And he went on, and there was yellow light and fire within, and the evening meal was ready, and he was expected. And Rose drew him in and set him in his chair and put little Eleanor upon his lap. He drew a deep breath. Well, I'm back, he said. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
但山姆转向了买水的地方，于是当白昼再次接近尾声时，他回到了山坡上。他继续往前走，里面透着黄色的灯光和炉火，晚餐已经准备好了，大家都在等他。罗斯拉着他走进屋，让他坐在椅子上，把小埃莉诺放在他的膝盖上。他深深地吸了一口气。好了，我回来了，他说。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听、
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少许八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。